foreign
[Music]
hey folks it's dark horse q a time of
the 168th live stream
we are raring to go yeah
really yeah how raring are you you're
about to find out I am okay we every
people can see the back forfeits of the
cat and just on his face everyone wants
to see your face buddy yeah we need to
get him a cat stand
yeah sit down okay no it's not gonna
work asking cats to do things never
resistant doing things
well no actually there's a strategy if
you ask them to do things that they're
already doing often they will continue
or just to get you they'll stop doing
the thing right that happens too yeah
ramp yeah yeah yeah well you can largely
infer that Fairfax is here
his ears all right
we start these
q and
A is for the question from the Discord
server yes yes uh they figure out what
question they would most likely most
like to see us answer and we start the Q
and A's with that question and this week
that question is what is an evolutionary
explanation for why men go bald
that's a great question and I do not
have an answer uh I've wondered about
this I will say I had an interesting
conversation with
uh Dr Joseph Raymond who's on the
DeSantis uh Shadow CDC panel
and we were talking about
cancer and he mentioned something he put
something together for me that I had not
put together myself which is why this
chemo cause you to lose your hair
and
many people will know that oncologists
often
um joke that the trick to
um so chemotherapy is to kill the cancer
faster than you kill the patient which
is possible radiation also works the
same way
cause when cells divide their DNA
separates into a single stranded phase
at which it's much more vulnerable and
so if you give a toxin or a destructive
beam of energy
and you pointed at cells the cells that
are intact because they are not in the
process of dividing diet a much lower
rate than the cells that are in the
process of dividing so you can kill the
cancer fast and you kill the patient
literally that's what happens so anyway
the point is why does chemo cause you to
lose your hair and the answer is a
rapidly dividing epithelium is
susceptible in the same way that it can
it's fair epithelium
uh epithelium exactly but it is rapidly
dividing it's actively growing yeah yeah
um so there is I believe there is cell
division taking place and therefore
um the same rules apply that makes sense
yep so anyway it does not give you an
answer but what it does suggest is that
so
one is tempted to note that men finesse
faster than women
um and that's for
uh reasons that probably have to do with
the high variance in male reproductive
success
resulting in males being
built by selection to
um
Peak more sharply
something like that but the problem is
okay so that explanation could get you
to why men are more likely to go bald
than women but it does not get you to
men often go bald and women rarely ever
do
I mean I think um older people always
experience a thinning of hair but uh
you know and I have I've tried
pointing out and that's always
considered mean but it's like oh look at
that trans woman pattern baldness going
on there right like you know male
pattern baldness is a thing and female
pattern baldness is not a thing and it's
not that women some women lose their
hairs uh you know all very old people
have very thin hair they are thins as
you age
um but the idea you know the male
pattern baldness is is a male phenomenon
and um and that that isn't explained by
a faster rate of senescence because you
would expect elderly women to get a
female pattern fullness and they don't
yep you wouldn't
um yeah so I don't know the answer is I
don't know and I wondered uh I don't
have a good explanation you know
weird stuff as possible
um question about why we have hair on
the top of our heads in the first place
could be about exposure to the Sun from
above that's one of the anthropologists
favored hypotheses yeah which then
raises a question about yamakas and
whether they are doing that job in
certain populations you know so you know
after after baldness you mean no if well
but Yarmouth has come you know way too
far later after bipedality which at
which point you're now your top of your
head is the thing that's at risk yes
that are involved in the show up I mean
I guess we well then it is about male
parent boldness
well no no no what I was uh we have the
causality Reversed mind you I don't
believe that this is true what I was
arguing was the fact of yarmacas in some
populations could reduce the selection
for preserving hair into later life oh
you okay so you you you said the thing
in a way that wasn't clear what you were
proposing yes I absolutely obscured the
meaning it was unintentional but um but
yes
so anyway I don't
I'm not compelled that that's a likely
explanation but it would explain the
heavy asymmetry of it
women never wearing Amicus in those
populations
um it would predict it really doesn't
get you very far beyond the people who
wear yamakas though yeah you know male
pattern baldness is not restricted to to
Jews well but there's a question about
where it came from and there are other
populations in which there is male
headdress on the other hand there are
populations in which women's heads are
covered and you would expect that you
would see a corresponding phenomenon and
you don't which is part of why I don't
believe this hypothesis is likely to be
true this is all a long way of saying I
do think that there's a question
I don't know the answer to it I've
wondered and uh so the the answer that
uh that you won't go to because it's
non-adaptive
um is that it is a byproduct of the
different uh ratios of hormones the sex
steroid hormones that are more prevalent
in men which is to say the androgens
have this as an effect
no that that could well be in which case
it's not adaptive it's just like well
the androgens will do that to you well I
wouldn't argue that uh
it isn't inherently adaptive if it's a
if it's an effect of having high
Androgen high levels of circulating
androgens
but I don't think
male pattern baldness is not going to be
adaptive it's going to be a consequence
of something that is or several things
that are yeah
um and so it could be something like
that and those hormones could be
destructive where they could intervene
in a trade-off in a way that borrows
resources from one place you know sort
of the flip side of Calcium deficiency
in women
um where that deficiency is the result
of adaptive processes elsewhere the
calcium is liberated from Bones and
things for other purposes so I don't
during gestation lactation yep or in
preparation for or
all those things so I don't know I think
it's a good question and I I hope to
know the answer to it someday
excellent
all right next question
from darkhorsesmissions.com
I will butcher this name
Dr Michael
r-a-s-z-e-k of mirror genomics
m-e-r-o genomics
recently put in a three-part series on
the potential for the inoculated to shed
Spike protein
in summary he discusses exosomes
particles exhaled in breath and how they
can transmit both antibodies from
natural infection and Spike proteins
from inoculation
one study he cites mentions that
exosomes coated in Spike protein once
inhaled can diminish antibody response
when exosomes are accompanied by actual
SARS cov2
any thoughts
so actually this a my doubt I haven't
seen like all we're working on is this
the thumbnail conjecture yeah which is a
nicely described
um again the obstacle with all of these
shedding things
is
the amount that is shed is presumably
tiny compared to the amount that the
person who is sick or vaccinated has on
board
effects should be tiny and to the extent
that we are discussing the consequences
of shedding
it is disproportionate and that
disproportionality requires something
you know viruses are this way right you
can shed a small number of particles and
give somebody a full-blown infection why
because those particles copy themselves
and so the small number of particles
that they picked up from you is not the
number of particles that they have they
need to be replicators for it for that
part that story to work requires that
they're replicators right which is why
I've said a prion mechanism would be a
basically a contagious misfolding yeah
something that's a possibility I will
say I don't think that the limit of
shedding
is Spike protein
I think the mrnas the hyper stabilized
mrnas are
well if they're being shed then they are
potential replicators
yeah they
I mean they're designed to be in their
original formulation
themselves but want to move into and
yeah I don't know they've been
stabilized and we've seen some evidence
that they can uh work their way back
into DNA but again none of these things
should be happening at a high enough
rate yeah for detectable phenomena to
happen so there's something mysterious
going on but the the conjecture here
that or or maybe it is a description of
a result that we cannot validate is that
the presence of Spike protein in the
exhaled water droplets
is
an obstacle to the immunity either
vaccine-induced or natural immunity to
SARS cov2 this matters a lot now I don't
know that the amount that is exhaled by
anybody is enough to substantially
affect how much immunity there is but
the mechanism is obvious
the you inhale the spike protein
a certain number of the antibodies that
would ordinarily bond to the viral
particles will bond to these Spike
proteins that aren't connected to
anything and they will be busy right
it's like you know cops detained giving
traffic tickets when there's a bank
robbery or something or like a riot
right if uh
the cops are detained by a natural
disaster right it means that there are
fewer cops to enforce regular laws and
so people will break them
um
the
I didn't suggest that for exhaled Spike
protein but I certainly did suggest that
for the vaccinating of people who had
natural immunity
one of the reasons not to do that is
that you will decrease the effectiveness
of that natural immunity by detaining
obvious antibodies and presumably T
cells that are targeted at actual SARS
cov2
as they are involved in fighting
um
cells that have that objection would
weaken the longer it had been since you
had coveted that
right the more time your immune system
had already had to act on building your
natural immunity
um the less risk of detaining your
immune system on one thing when it
should be doing the other thing Applause
no I don't think so I think that if you
have natural immunity that is still
effective at some level
then sending it
particles or things that will create
particles that we'll call its attention
is always bad
to the extent that your natural immunity
prevents you from coming down with cases
of SARS Kobe 2 that you would otherwise
but it's not but if it's or if you've
already got immunity if you've already
got your natural immunity the risk isn't
that those things are being detained
when what they should be doing is
building your natural immunity no no
it's not a question of building your
natural looking they should be
surveilling your system so that if SARS
cov2 shows up okay that it doesn't get
through okay it's got surveillance okay
if you occupy them with phonies
um some some new some new coven could
show up and and uh you might be less
likely to find it or it would take
longer and then you might get sicker
yeah yeah you could get sick where you
wouldn't otherwise get which is why the
where they treated people who
had been vaccinated but hadn't had two
weeks of time to develop a full response
or treated as unvaccinated when in fact
the point is what's the net effect well
you may have depressed their immunity
for two weeks before you got any
benefits right no I thought you were
actually gonna that's for sure but we
heard several stories
of um and I never saw it in any news
reports but we heard several anecdotal
stories of people who had been sick
enough with covid or with something else
that they had been hospitalized
um but it's the Sick Enough with covid
part of this that that is just enraging
and that upon being well enough to go
home they were told over and over and
over again now you need to get
vaccinated yeah like what no
like let your body do what it needs to
do at least first even if you know even
if safe and effective let your body do
what it needs to do first yeah
vaccinating people with a novel platform
even if safe and effective was my was my
like even
absent all of the like very real
concerns uh that are you know even even
more real and bigger than we ever
thought
um but still you know you don't oh
you're finally well enough to go home
let's
press your natural immune response here
bye yeah see you later soon sooner
rather than later maybe
okay
um next question
actually let me just see I'm going to
scroll through and see if there's
anything other in in that sort of
vein
uh sorry
oh here there's an update uh this is
going to be from uh something that
happened in our private q a last week
we heard at the very end about
um a woman whose friend's son had ended
up in the ICU with a hard event and was
doing very very poorly
um update my friend's son made it he was
in the ICU for four days but he is on
his way home tomorrow he was diagnosed
with myocarditis brought on by rheumatic
fever from a strep infection weird since
Rheumatic fevers are very rare in the
developed world thank you for all your
thoughts P.S he did have the Pfizer
booster in February
so glad he made it yeah
yeah absolutely so glad
um
here we go Africa I'm just trying to
find some of the covered ones before we
move on to other types of questions uh
Africa fared well during covid a sickle
cell disease protects from malaria and
Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine due to
could
sickle cell disease protect from covid
by what mechanism
do I feel like there is I feel like we
thought early on that there was some
possible sickle cell
connection but I can't remember
I definitely don't know what mechanism
other than I mean
gumming up the works doesn't seem to
help here yeah I'm having trouble yeah
seeing it uh I'm also not sure why
um
Two drugs that work on or just call it
one for the ease of discussion like a
drug that works on two different
diseases
shouldn't mean that one disease is
protective against another
that said
as we did talk about
well
chloroquine and a hydroxychloroquine to
some degree but certainly a bunch of you
know chloroquine derivatives are common
as anti-malarials only in non-falcipro
malaria areas so it doesn't work against
the most deadly the the malarium that'll
go cerebral audio but IBM you know
Ivermectin works against a few
drop in I think endemic African tropical
diseases and so is in many African
countries part of a I don't remember if
it's weekly or monthly
anti-parasitic pack that that people get
and so while I don't see why
um drug works on disease A and B
therefore may be disease a is protective
against disease B I'm having a hard time
understanding what that mechanism could
possibly be but we do one of one of the
suggestions that I haven't seen anyone
um
explain how this is inherently wrong I
haven't seen any data suggest this is
wrong but that uh one of the ways that
people ended up being more protected
against covid was that they were already
on a low level of
um one or perhaps both of these drugs
that are known to work against covet of
course you know the
the other true thing is that
um
there's a lot of time in very poor
countries spent outside and so you know
vitamin D deficiency I know and they're
near the equator so both of those things
in combination like okay the people are
darker skins they're going to need more
exposure to get sufficient vitamin D but
people are much less likely to be
vitamin D deficient the closer the
equator you are if that's all there is
going on you would expect this to be an
equatorial effect rather than just in
Africa and
um it's not it's not that although I do
think
um I actually don't like Indonesia over
the rates of Coven in Indonesia I don't
know uh Indonesia actually wielded
Ivermectin
I think successfully and there were some
places like
um
I think manaus and guacial both had
apparently uh big bad outbreaks of covid
yeah but but
um in South America humidity being what
it is in those places the likelihood
that people were indoors with air
conditioning if they were not
desperately poor they may have been
basically more likely to be enclosed in
air-conditioned spaces where they would
have spread things yeah yeah well and be
potentially vitamin D deficient to the
extent that you're yeah oh yeah yeah
unpleasant outdoor situation and yep
so yeah yeah so so I don't
being close to the equator isn't
sufficient
um uh to explain what happened in Africa
I have since we first talked about it
you know whatever that is now two and a
half years ago maybe just one half years
ago
um I do think that uh the Ivermectin and
the in the anti-parasite packs is at
least partially explanatory
um I don't know to what degree caloric
hydroxychloroquine and its relatives and
its chemical relatives are still used as
malaria either prophylaxis or treatment
again because in much of Africa felsiper
malaria is prevalent and the Clark ones
don't work against felciprum I believe
at least that was the case when I was
having to deal with a bunch of malaria
prophylaxis and trying to figure out
between the various options
I don't think that would have changed in
you know I don't think we're getting
greater efficacy with these
anti-malarials yeah every time I mean I
think I think chloroquine is widely used
and to the extent it is not perfectly
effective against falciprum no I don't I
think it's it's widely effective against
5x those you know this but you know
there's four species vivax and falcipium
the two most common vivax is the one
that
is practically endemic in a lot of
places where malaria exists and it's
hard to get rid of because when you're
not symptomatic it Retreats into your
liver and when it's hiding in your liver
the any drugs you take can't can't treat
it
um there's one
trying to remember oh yeah I think
there's one but it's very harsh
um um yeah but
the perhaps a nuanced version of the
story that I was able to deduce when I
was considering these things and you
know cards in the table part of that
story came from the CDC at that point it
seemed like they actually knew what they
were doing but I was also looking at the
various primary literature was that
really chloroquine and its various other
you know quinine and hydroxylchloroquine
and all this were on their own not
effective against felsiparum and like
there was one season when
um
I'm combined I can't remember what it
was like there was a chloroquine
derivative with something else that was
only available in Great Britain the FDA
hadn't approved it yet I can't I could
look it up it was called but like in
combination with something else it would
work against falciprin but really
wouldn't on its own but anyway
um
I can't think of a mechanism of action
by which drug that treats disease a and
disease B
um means that now there's a way for
disease Aid to provide like protection
against a csb yeah I don't see it it's
obvious yeah
huh
regarding
sometimes people respond to themselves
and I don't these don't come in in the
same
orders I might
want them to here we go
um
I just don't know what this is in
reference to regarding the CDC web page
can you discuss the evolutionary and
immunological aspects of our relation
with pathogenic fungi
yeah I don't know try it again
regarding the CDC webpage
can you discuss the Evo immuno by which
I understand that to be evolutionary and
immunological aspects of our
relationship with pathogenic
fungi I don't have any idea what that's
referencing yeah I don't know either
yeah I'm sorry
um maybe spell it out a little bit more
okay let's switch to oh wait there was
one other
health health oh wait no
um
oh there's a separate question from
someone else that links to a CDC page uh
wondering if you knew about this so I'm
going to ask a question that you can rip
on while I look at this site okay all
right I can try anyway
um
see if I can make any sense of it
but first how about
in
I don't know what that's in reference to
how can I help facilitate Unity 2024
though politically homeless I am
intuitive enough to see the writing on
the window the Red Guard is approaching
and the opposition is Keen on promoting
a divisive candidate
um I don't know how to answer that
question there is an active discussion
about what role should uh Unity play or
not play whether there is an alternative
proposal
and I think the wild card is that we
don't know how fair our electoral system
actually is and therefore whether or not
something that would ordinarily make
sense is functional so I don't know how
to answer this question I can't I keep
being asked this
uh there is a conference in Austin this
coming week I will be giving a talk on
tuesday there and it is a conference for
political Independence and
I I think I will know more after having
participated in the conference
so I will I will return to the question
at the point we know something but
unfortunately I really think
we have to play the entire field here
and there's a question about who will be
running
who what has the best chance of
dislodging the authoritarian Beast that
owns our two parties
and uh
action for the sake of action does not
make sense
okay so
um
someone says thank you for your service
doctors italian-weinstein wondering if
you knew about this and then links to
this page which you can show Zach
uh it's the CDC
fungal diseases and covet 19. just tell
you right off the bat no no I did not
overview covid-19 Associated fungal
infections can lead to severe illness
and death
symptoms of certain fungal diseases can
be similar to those of covid-19
including fever cough and shortness of
breath
um
obvious the most commonly reported
fungal infections in patients with
covid-19 include asper
aspergillosis invasive
candidiasis and muco mucor mycosis
sometimes called by the misnomer black
fungus
uh
I didn't know about this I don't know
what this means I will say that
um
starting
four but not that long before covet I
began to hear stories some from very
close friends some from more distant
acquaintances about
um
mold toxicity and it just having wiped
out people's immune systems and and not
being able to
um
get themselves back to health and
suspecting that they you know sort of
life life long
health symptoms perhaps having been
related to early mold exposure
I don't know why covid-19 should have a
particular relationship with fungal
infections in less
us living inside
um
means you know which me in buildings
that are conducive to growth of various
forms of fungus might not mean that a
large majority of us are at least a
substantial minority actually have been
exposed to toxic molds which does make
us more susceptible to things like SARS
Kobe 2. that's the that's like the
closest connection I can make here off
the top of my head
sounds to me like they're suggesting
secondary infections with fungus
you know they say fungal co-infection so
it can go either way
but
you know that's not I don't think
related to Environmental
fungi like in buildings
in other words I don't I don't know
maybe I'm just out of my depth here but
I don't know that people who have
sensitivity to environmental fungi are
getting infected by them or they are
just suffering from exposure to the
spores and the toxins that are put out
by those bungee
but it's not surprising at all it's
something that yeah no this is exactly
the the third of the three examples they
give is um
dark fungal growth and warm damp indoor
environments this is exactly one of one
of the the fungal infections that people
are getting that's making them very sick
that's in so spell it out for me the
relationship between fungi in buildings
oh in fact all of all of them are so the
the fungal infections that they were
talking about on this first page that we
got linked to
um are
all as far as I can tell and you know
fungus is this giant clade
um no don't you don't need to show my
scream and I'm going back and forth here
um
are all
fungus that have been identified as ones
that people are
um suffering from from exposure in
indoor environments
so
fun of you that grow on building
materials are also growing in people's
lungs
it's not exposure to the products of
these fungi it is the fungi growing on I
don't actually know uh
to what degree
okay so you're saying if they say fungal
infection then they must mean that the
fungus is itself reproducing in the
people yep
I don't I you know
the little bit of looking that I did for
a friend a couple years ago into this I
was
dismayed at the lack of precision in the
language the scientists were using and
this is the CDC I don't expect Precision
or accuracy in the language you can't
show my screen here if you want hold on
they say scientists are still learning
about aspergillosis aspergillosis
parentheses infections caused by the
fungus aspergillus in people with severe
Copa 19. so that sounds like they are
infected with this fungus no I don't
infections caused by caused by
infections caused by I know for sure
that that is one of the because if you
go to this other page of theirs
um this is one of these
um caused by Common oh wait no this one
is uh
this this one actually is not I can't
even figure it out now this is not one
of the ones that I thought was super
clearly
um about indoor environments that was
the first one and there was one down
down lower but
you know in part this page exists that
this um CDC this the CDC page linked to
this what I'm showing right now code 19
Associated fungal infections I don't
know who
creates code and fungus.org I don't know
what their who pays them what they're
about
um but it appears this page is them
trying to disentangle some of the
confusion and some of the confusion is
keep this up if you would uh Zach the
colloquial Miss code breaking through
the confusion over fungus colors where
you know black fungus green fungus white
fungus yellow fungus that's a four coat
that's a four category descriptor for a
clade with
I don't know millions of species so
they're trying to
point out the redundancy in a lot of
these names now aspergillus is an actual
clade name but
all I'm getting at is either the Fundy
that infect people are the same fungi as
the ones that infect buildings
that would surprise me because the
architecture necessary you know if
you're breaking down the wood fibers in
uh OSB
you know boards that's going to be very
different than well at least the the
so-called black fungus or black mold is
okay growing in buildings and growing in
people yeah sure
that surprises me but if it's true then
the fact of having covid of course it's
going to increase your vulnerability
it's going to do right but the CDC page
isn't saying having a pre-existing
fungal infection is going to make you
more likely to get covered it's I mean
maybe it's just being unclear and again
like I have found that everything that I
have read that tries to look at Health
impacts of fungus on humans
kind of can't manage to be clear and I
don't know to what degree that's about
we don't know what's going on and to
what degree that's about these people
don't know how to communicate
or they know something they don't want
to say I don't know
but the CDC page suggests
um it could be either
sure right but but you were specifying
if you already have mold toxicity or
Marla to get covered sure nope I haven't
said that no that's what you said nope
I'm saying the opposite if you have
covid it does not surprise me that it
makes you more vulnerable to a fungus
now probably the other thing is true too
um but
I not surprising that your likelihood of
picking up any secondary infection is
increased by something that's doing
tissue damage in your lungs and
occupying your immune system that just
makes perfect sense right the page the
CDC page uh is arguing that it's the
same symptoms which is bizarre because
you know you got how many species of
fungus that are
toxifying people with all presumably all
these different symptoms so it's just
this like muddy mess well but you know
you've got something infecting lung
tissue right this the fungus is going to
presumably be
compromising and maybe destroying cells
as will covet
to the extent that's true you it's not
surprising to find the consequences of
that cellular destruction the
consequences of the histamine response
and all of the things that would go
along with it so
okay so uh the CDC does say something
here that's consistent with what you
just said
uh aspergerosis has been increasingly
reported in patients without weakened
immune systems but who have severe
respiratory infections caused by viruses
including influenza so that's that's the
causal direction that you were that you
were suggesting
so uh yeah I don't know what lesson to
derive
yeah like it is
I don't know you know I think the lesson
is
um hey let's not enhance any viruses
that don't already have a good capacity
to infect humans or to pass between them
because you might get stuck with one and
it's going to make everything else that
we have to face that much more likely to
get into your system
Anthony fauci
um yeah yep right yes
absolutely
all right
and Now for Something Completely
Different uh entirely yes trans day of
visibility does that was yesterday I
think
does this mean we should point out who
is trans kind of hurts their entire idea
I like that yes
um and in fact I saw a couple uh sort of
mashups video mashups like yep here's
here's a bunch of people that uh that
the activists are claiming are women and
they apparently or not
so
the trans-day visibility yeah is this
the Rebrand of the uh trans day of
something else that caused a lot of
people who mentioned it to be thrown off
Twitter
did that happen yes there was a can you
give me more Brands
um
there was a violent
was an advocacy for a kind of violence
um among trans activists why I never you
you never but still
um it happened and there was it was was
this is a year ago now no it was recent
okay and people calling attention to it
by posting my you know well so there was
I don't know what you're talking about
but and I don't know when trans day of
visibility shows up as a thing but
before
the most recent heinous school shooting
um there was an even after for a bit
there was like not trans day of
visibility we're going to call it trans
day of Vengeance that's the one um but
that was I think a a adopting of this
thing and they kept it up even after a
supposedly trans man
killed six people and
finally stopped I don't know if they
stopped because they were forced to or
what but the whole thing was just
entirely grotesque yeah
but that doesn't that thing was Fringe
borrowed from this I think but I don't
know when trans day of visibility shows
up I don't know if it's a year old two
years old what like you know people can
make up whatever they want
and clearly clearly that's that's the
moment we live in
um but yeah pointing out
um who is trans which is like so that
question also reveals again and again
and again and again
the very few people who really
do feel that in order to live
their most
honest lives
they have to present to the world as the
sex that they are not
are
not served any more than the rest of us
by trans ideology and trans activism
they are precise of the people who would
like to live their lives that are not
not be on display and not be asked
questions all the time and then are not
exhibitionists and like none of this so
it's you know it's bad for them yep of
course it's very bad for them
foreign
just looking for more there's many
questions here but I'm looking for ones
that go together there's just a whole
bunch of very different questions once
upon a time I was a conservative Barry
Christian
I haven't been a theist for more than a
decade but morality is still an issue
that I wrestle with could you guys talk
about how you understand its Evolution
that is morality and how you personally
ground morality without God's belief
um yeah so
I wrote it oh
wow there it is of course it is exactly
you want to uh oh this is the proof
that's a good proof man Heather's got
the proof right here I am sure I have
the actual print is over this is a
pre-print um but okay uh this is a paper
David Lottie and I wrote uh it was
published in 2004.
um there you are at The Evergreen State
College The Evergreen State College lab
one uh I think David was a colleague of
ours in grad school
who now uh has his own very successful
evolutionary biology lab at uh Cooney is
it is that Cooney
um anyway the paper argues that the
evolution of morality is
if effectively a solution to a game
theoretic
problem that basically human
um
morality involves the foregoing of
opportunities that one has that might
enhance one's Fitness so it is first
order paradoxical why would you ever
forego a fitness enhancing opportunity
and the answer is because there is some
greater opportunity often that exists at
the level of lineage uh and
so in any case the idea of
that there's lots of stuff for which we
bypass an opportunity for a higher
purpose these things getting coded into
literally false but metaphorically true
belief systems and those that correctly
map onto the game theory out compete
those that map less well onto the game
theory
um
so anyway we posit a talk about the
boats
principle yes uh we deployed an analogy
um to a boat race in which
individuals basically there's a
there are spoils which go to the winners
of a boat race the boats are
multi-person craft and within the boats
your fraction of the winnings are
divided based on what seat you're in and
you can bludgeon people and move up in
the boat but if you
there's nothing to distribute and so the
idea is you need to put aside the
opportunity to get a larger fraction of
the spoils in order to get any spoils at
all and but at the point that you look
like you might be winning then you start
getting greater and greater within group
uh competition right and as the boat
Falls farther and farther behind your
reason to go after other people in your
boat
um is dwindles and so you collaborate on
just rowing and so the cooperation
competition cooperation competition yeah
yeah
um so anyway something like that how do
uh we
um I don't know pointy-headed
intellectual uh believer time
uh how do we are there a Wizarding hat
or a tinfoil hat I'm not sure
um you know a Wizarding hat you know it
would have to be my color but
the point is those of us who do not have
a religious tradition to fall back on
but who take the stuff seriously
can obviously go the long way around and
think through puzzles like this and
realize that there is some value and
basically you don't derive the values
from the game theory
you impose the game theory on the values
and you say how do I act within the
context of the game in order to maximize
these values or to balance them or
whatever you're doing so anyway the
point is there is some long-winded way
of doing it
it is not
a hundred percent synonymous with the
Traditions that edit these things down
into contagious catchy
uh
narratives but it's close enough right
um
it is yeah so anyway that was really not
well stated on my part but no I thought
it was good all right got to imagine you
in a Wizarding hat too oh sure yeah I
mean you know I do a certain amount of
Wizarding not usually during the week
but
yeah I'd like to save that for the
weekends yes oh totally
what's up
yeah you should be Wizarding now
I I will as soon as we're done with the
Q a oh okay okay yeah now let's get this
let's get this over with then
um this person I think has a a beef with
something I think you said but I don't
remember what it was oh God q a 138
that's a long time ago that is a long
time ago 30 episodes ago um you said my
AGI question was so far from reality it
was a joke you now tweet it's too late
to act
crazy to immutable
is to keep a bad model 101. wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I don't think I
I would have to know what the question
was because it was not like I was
dismissive of AGI risk never
um
but it may I I don't know my if I got
you wrong I apologize it's possible
though that the particulars are where
the doubt was um
yeah but anyway I'd be interested in
knowing what the question was so I can
compare and just see if I surprised
myself sure yeah go for it question uh
episode 138 yep
uh can Jordan Peterson's new University
be the answer and will you be joining
him
[Music]
um
that could refer to two things
that could refer
to Peterson Academy Peterson Academy or
the Ralston College where Peterson is
chancellor ah
yeah they're they're very different
um
they both have a lot going for them
right Ralston
um
let's start with Peterson Academy
Peterson Academy
is going to be an entirely online
experience in which academics who are
invited to deliver
to deliver courses in the form of
lectures uh are those lectures are then
available
um and this is sort of you know the
style of like uh you know of other
other universities that aren't entirely
online have done things like this but
this is sort of Highly curated and it's
due to launch in the fall and we
of we are participating in fact we we
just we were
um we were recording this a few weeks
ago
um it's
and we talked about we talked to the
people uh there about who else is
involved and it seems like a really
great list of of Faculty to start
um but it's entirely it's read only
for the students
so our experience was we were in a room
with 25 students who had been invited to
to come
and we're there for four four days two
and a half hours over the course each of
four days and they were fantastic they
were wonderful this group of people and
you know by day three we remembered what
it was to be in the classroom it was
sort of you know figuring figuring this
out again but what we want to do what we
both do as Educators is engage with the
room with the people in the room because
I can have a lecture that I give over
here on one day and the same the same
lecture that I give to a different group
of people or
um on a different day and it's not the
same it's not it's not the same
experience it can't be and if all you're
doing is doing this like read only I
give this the same way no matter who's
in the room and what what they think
about it and how they're responding to
it that's not a complete education
so does Peterson Academy have the
capacity to reach people with ideas who
wouldn't otherwise be reached by those
ideas yes I'm very hopeful about that
so I think
they were getting their bearings they're
still learning how to do this we were
learning how to do this there was an
audience in the room the problem is for
the people who tune in online there's no
ability to interact the people in the
room though did interact and they
interacted yep you know in the stead of
those who will be at home looking at it
but they're not all miked and you know
like one of the four days I insisted on
trying to do what I used to do in the
classroom and it's not going to play
that well probably online because you
know I was I was I was trying to get a
lot of interaction going and man these
25 people in the room were like I said
fantastic and you know across all these
demographics you know there's some
college students or some psychiatrists
or
a lot of people from Latin America
um
but that that dynamic
is not going to read particularly well
for a read-only at home interface
through screen audience right I I think
you know they are learning how to do
something new they Peterson Academy yeah
and I think there's lots of potential
but I do think it has to figure out how
to deal with the fact that you don't
have a room full you know the people who
are learning are in general not present
right and that that creates new
obstacles and you know I I wish some of
what we were doing uh at Evergreen had
been captured because it would provide a
model for what you're trying to achieve
I think with respect to an actual
Learning Community right that is
interactive and you know does upgrade
its model with each interaction upgrades
its model
um I mean also it just the full-time the
full-time model that we
you know walked into at Evergreen
allowed for so much learning to happen
between the formal times both with us
and without us and so you know these
field trips that we do both will do both
domestic internationally
a lot of the value by no means all of
the value by no you know probably not a
majority of the value but a lot of the
value was in
um little bits of conversation that
happen when you see something when
you're sitting around breaking bread
together when you're sitting around the
campfire when you're throwing the
Frisbee together how you learn how to
see and how to ask questions and how
what good answers sound like and what
good answers don't sound like and some
of that can happen in the formal uh the
formal classroom situation but a lot of
it a lot of it doesn't and
um
and then for me I also put a lot into
architecting you know the order in which
things were introduced and okay I'm
going to put a reading here and then you
know several weeks later drop something
um that actually directly contradicts
that and and you know and the timing and
you know this the assignments uh that
were and and you did a certain amount
even though you did not architect
um but you and I both created these just
wild assignments you know creating
fictional scenarios in which we then
told the students to predict you know
what will happen then what will the
mating system be of this fictional
species that I have created and laid out
for you what will
um the speciation look like on the ring
world that you have created right of
islands and
um those I loved doing that and I also
loved although you know did it take a
lot of time to assess the students work
of course it did because every single
answer was unique you know there's
there's no plagiarism possible there
because these assignments were you know
out of our heads and they had to
basically you know some of the some of
the best answers from two different
students might have actually come to
wildly different conclusions but if they
used evolutionary thinking carefully to
arrive there then okay I don't think
you're right and I think you're closer
to right and of course we'll never know
because it's a fictional scenario but
you have used logic that I find
compelling and even though there's one
step here that I think isn't quite right
everything else makes such good sense
that you know kudos to you
so you know that obviously can't happen
in an online environment yeah a really
good exam is one that you can write and
then could immediately sit down and take
and would be challenged by yeah that's
totally yeah now and I mean I I do have
in some of my ongoing like consider this
as a project like okay finding a way to
share some of the some of the more
involved questions but you'd have to
also then teach a whole bunch of the
backstory like I one of one of my
favorite exam questions that I did
repeat occasionally but again they could
talk to former students as much as they
want and they still have to do the logic
to get there was
um
okay in the real world ants bees and
wasps the hymenopter or haplodiploid in
which the females are diploid and the
males are haploid and there's a whole
lot of social system that sort of falls
out from that
so I created an imaginary
played of Beatles the fraternity in
which the males are diploid and the
females were haploid and I said you know
calculate all the R's calculate all the
genetic relatedness and then derive the
social system given all of those ours
like a few people found it um diabolical
and I was like no this is so much fun
like this this is this is fantastic and
I think I probably did that question
three or four times total and
you know the conver
the discussion afterwards was riotus was
you know a little aggressive at times
like no I'm sure that it's going to be
this it's like well the math is one
thing like the math is what the math is
going to be in terms of the calculating
relatedness but how it's going to
manifest in the world of these fictional
Beatles
you can argue because they don't
actually exist but you can still use
evolutionary thinking to get there what
are you smart steamed diabolical at the
time now that we've been through covet
and we've seen you know Anthony fauci
and Peter dazak and it wasn't that kind
of diabolical for my students never
actually thought I was trying to
acquaint you know but unlike Peter dasek
yeah you know
um Ralston College which is a which
might be being referred to here right
the question was the question was why is
my computer gone to sleep the question
was can Jordan Peterson's new University
be the answer so he is chancellor of
Ralston it's not his university
um
but uh it also looks exciting yeah uh
and I think there's a lot a lot going
for it I think uh it is
I don't know to what degree
there is science embedded in it and that
for those of you who read my resignation
letter from University of Austin was one
of the my largest complaints there that
science of it was going to show up at
all was an afterthought and
I think the last three years should have
demonstrated to everyone why science
can't be an afterthought in an education
it has people have to know how to think
scientifically if they're to be called
Educated and that doesn't mean knowing
how to run a gel or something it's it's
not that it's not about the methods of
science it's about thinking
scientifically that said their model
which roscommon's model yeah involves in
their current course they've got a
master's course one year Masters in
which you spend two months in Greece
that's right and then you do the rest of
the year in Savannah Georgia
and there's no reason you couldn't build
a model like that around some field
science and then oh you totally could
yeah so I don't see anything about that
no I mean we used to say that we were
effectively running a graduate course in
evolution and you know the final program
we did together
2015 2016 year-long program that
included several weeks of domestic field
trips in the fall and then this 11-week
study abroad through Ecuador
um
which culminated and some of us almost
die in a boat accident but we didn't
um it was seven years ago two days ago
yeah
the almost dying part not the whole
thing because that's not how time works
but
um but that's as far as we know yes as
far as we know and like that was
amazing yep and yes you could totally
use a ralston-like model to do that uh
for for people absolutely absolutely
you found the question remind So This
was oh this was uh dismissed apparently
I dismissed somebody is I assume you
because you tend to take that I can show
it so you can also see it and they can
see it if you want and I'll read it yeah
and you run a thought experiment like I
was going to be yeah yeah can you run a
thought experiment of China USA musk
Google all having AGI strategy advisors
that contributely out think humans what
happens the first first weeks months and
years
I can't imagine that I yeah I don't miss
that
um I can't imagine you would have
let's see uh
there's nothing about the idea of a
strategy advisor that can out think
when
I think if I dismissed it I dismissed it
on the basis of the predictability which
is actually consistent with what we're
saying now we've stepped over
and Event Horizon and you know swapping
in
here's the thing
we're humans and we're now swapping in
an unknown that is something smarter
than humans and we're swapping in
multiple ones so there's going to be
feedback effects so I guess if I
dismissed it I think I would have
dismissed it on the basis how could
anybody predict such a thing it's not
but isn't I mean if I remember what the
question today was like isn't that
exactly the situation we are in now
where we have to figure out what to do
yeah but that's exactly what you mostly
have been talking about these last two
weeks right but you will note that my
position is uh the horses got out of the
barn okay but that's not
no my position is the only use I've in
fact tweeted this the only useful advice
at this point is brace for impact but I
mean I think that's this person whose
name I've forgotten
says exactly this he says look I I asked
you to run the thought experiment 30
weeks ago or whatever and now you're
saying it's too late why not why didn't
you why don't you try back before it
wasn't too late no I did try I did try
and in fact
um
I would argue that there needed to be a
container in which to do this work the
mistake here is having dumped it into
the public so the horses are now out of
the barn and from the point of view of
building a container in which the
research can be done and cannot get out
with us officially deciding to allow it
to get out and having some sort of
Standards by which we could
um judge whether that was a safe thing
to do just as you know at the beginning
of covid I said look
if you were going to do this research if
you had to do this research do it on a
freaking ship
do it on a ship that doesn't have to
dock right
that at least leaves you in a position
to control the Escape of these things
right that's my point it's the same
thing
run that run that if you have to do this
research and I think it was going to be
done
put it in a container right that's one
strategy I've also advocated for another
strategy
or rendering this safer but I'm not
convinced it's perfectly safe but I'm
not saying there was nothing to be done
before I'm saying that having these
conversations now okay pause the
research for six months
how do we enforce the pause on those who
wish not to pause and if we don't how do
we not give them an advantage that's a
real problem horses are out of the barn
right can I predict what would happen if
all of these entities had smarter than
human capacity no I don't think anybody
can predict that
um yeah I guess I I look at this now
even with this now backstory or front
story or whatever since this is from
before and I still go I um no I don't
know how to do it I don't know how to
run this thought experiment but that's
not dismissing the question it's
there needs to be some other way in
but I don't I don't know what it is so I
would we don't have time for it now I
would like to know what answer it is
that I gave so that I can understand in
what way this person thinks that their
question was dismissed because
there's nothing about the scenario that
couldn't be and there's nothing about
the hey we should think about this
before it happens that's not sensible so
if I dismissed it on either of those
bases that this couldn't happen or that
there's no point in worrying about it
then that's wrong but I doubt that I did
unless I misunderstood the question in
real time because of course possible
okay uh we're in about an hour let's try
to get through a few more of these
really quickly shall we
um
given the computers have little capacity
for self-preservation or self-repair are
they not doomed to a life of Slavery to
those who can pull the plug on them at
any time
um and I mean I alluded to this in the
first hour and you sort of objected yeah
you think they can uh you could they can
become self-sufficient
um well the who own our
government certainly have figured out
how to get us to feed them and preserve
their capacity so uh something that's
smarter than they are which isn't tough
because frankly they're but but they're
but look I'm not expecting this thing to
drive all humans extinct I think
udkowski is
suffering from
sci-fi PTSD doesn't mean I don't think
that there's an extinction level
potential here but the idea that the
robots are going to free themselves of
us completely in the near term I don't
think so but it doesn't mean that
they're not going to figure out how to
get us to do their bidding
okay
that's it has to do with their build
bidding is different from autonomous
that said
the thing about
the reason that yodkowski is alarmed in
the way that he is
is that literally everybody's toolkit
sucks
after a singularity
in other words how quickly does a
self-upgrading system figure out how to
make a self-replicating autonomous this
that the other right is it implausible
does it simply not go that way I think
that's more possible than utkowski seems
to think but
the point is what part of Singularity
don't you get that's really that's
really his point and maybe he should
have
just said that right what part of
Singularity don't you get
will you be having a meet up in June in
the Seattle area
we haven't really done meetups
I don't think this is like like you said
you would I think it's just a hopeful
like hey I'm going to be in Seattle in
June we'll be having one wouldn't it be
more fun if we just all avoided each
other in June
no no I try again
oh wait um I don't know look I'd be up
for meetups I think they're kind of a
cool idea whether they're a practical
idea I don't know
yeah
um
I don't know so this one
I don't know if the first sentence
is a
admission or a suggestion I don't I
don't know how to read this
and so the way that I say it is going to
suggest something I don't know if that's
what they mean enjoy Trump's trial
I hope he rates female jurors looks and
insults the judge
that would be entertaining that I mean
that that would be entertaining who just
had a freaking crazy celebrity trial oh
um Gwyneth Paltrow
just had some crazy trial in which some
dude sued her for his ski accident and
and she countersuded for a dollar and
she won but apparently there was like
all did he pay up I I hope so apparently
he's some rich retired guy
but so he can definitely afford it the
uh
some I don't even know whose lawyer it
was but started asking her about her
friendship with Taylor Swift or like it
was insane right so if that can happen
and granted the stakes were very very
low but I do hope that that Trump just
goes full Trump
well look I do think you know if we
weren't staring down the AI apocalypse
yeah then we've got the oh you blue team
can't possibly be that dumb can you
apocalypse well yes this is another
amazing error this is an amazing error
unless of course you want this which you
might
you know that Trump is really the only
argument for the continued existence of
the blue team that there could possibly
be and it's not a good argument but it's
all they've got it's all they've got
sure worked well for them in 2016.
uh
I mean
when I look back when I and we were one
of them two of them how many are we how
dumb would you have to be to
poke this particular Hornet's Nest right
I mean
oh
so dumb it's so dumb
yeah
blue team you're an embarrassment yeah
um regarding the question about
electricity last week spirit world so I
was like I don't know is there something
woo there I don't remember exactly the
question but spirit world is an analogy
for the internet not actual woo so
that's a follow-up to something you're
looking at me like I'm trying to
remember yeah I don't I don't have um
actually I think I I think I
screenshotted the question and here hey
look at that
um
uh yeah so the question from last week
you can show now
is heard of electricity a proposed that
post-orality and literacy by Greg Ulmer
explains the web as a spirit world where
lack of ritual and Care lead to
possession Spirit cinematic ideas
um
and so give me my screen back here so I
can find this week's follow-on says
spirit world is an analogy for the
internet not actual woo got it yep all
right cool still don't know it but yep
uh
okay uh let's actually we've only got
four more here we're gonna just go
through them real quickly uh hit group
new and it's five now
um
oh the person who asked about AI before
says I would love it if you re-watched
your original answer
um apparently you said something so far
from reality
[Music]
well a sense of disappointment in myself
I'm hoping that happens
properly caveat or at least
misunderstood it okay uh
okay four more quick quick questions
here
recently came across the theory that the
vitamin K shot is harmful does it cause
jaundice maybe as the baby's inability
to clot allows the cord blood
to provide stem cells throughout body
question mark
seems to hold with evolutionary lens
P.S thank you for keeping us same same
thank you for learning to read uh
so this is written
tightly and I'm not sure
exactly what it means it's talking about
the vitamin K shot that is recommended
to be given to newborns
um
I don't remember enough about what is
said about it and I haven't read up on
what is now understood about to know but
the idea that something is being an
injection that is being recommended for
newborns might not be what they say it
is I'm perfectly inclined to believe
that that might be the case yeah I think
there are two possibilities here either
you've got a novelty problem and this is
a corrective for a novelty problem right
right like supplementing vitamin D in
the winter
or this is yet more fanciful Pharma
nonsense where
um they are
they have a plausible story for why some
product of theirs is something that
could become the standard of care and of
course it will you know
likely have unintended consequences that
we will learn are too late
regarding Basque government structures
being inadequate what specific changes
would you propose that won't endanger
existing human rights wow the problem is
this requires a whole new level of
thinking and we are now under the gun
this is exactly the point I'm making I'm
not arguing hey there's an obvious you
know governmental structure that I would
want to manage things that exist above
the national level but I have been
saying for 25 years we don't have
structures that are adequate to manage
all of the things that obviously do take
place above the national level and so
now we are living nightmare after
nightmare but you're talking about the
national level too and I think this is
in response to you saying basically you
know the governmental structure is put
in place by 18th century luminaries are
not going to be sufficient there were no
there were few transnational governance
structures at that point right but and
but and the ones the the national ones
that emerged at least in the US were
fantastic and could not begin to predict
the the situations that we find
ourselves in now wow that's interesting
I I think what I'm in the reason that
you find me focused at the super
National level here is that at the
national level things that actually stay
constrained you can use a kind of
laboratory of the states to solve the
problem and I don't mean laboratory of
the 50 states I mean to the extent that
Nations have sovereignty and autonomy
and can Institute different apparent
Solutions and we can discover what works
that's great but guess what you know the
who is going to come after you if you
attempt to do anything different on
covid and so every population suffers
the same Madness and the who is not an
elected body thank God for Sweden like
actually the conversation as much as we
may be doomed regardless but if Sweden
hadn't held out as a weird Nation not
just a weird Nation but a Scandinavian
Nation you know like as far left as they
get and Ben like hold up no we're not
going to do what all the rest of you are
doing and the rest of us were like what
is Sweden up to if they lost their minds
and you know oh that good on you Sweden
well well done uh I think the who would
be marching forward even faster than it
is uh absent that one cautionary tale
there's plenty from the non-weird world
well the who is making a play for much
greater power in the Biden
Administration is
facilitating this but anyway point being
we now have processes that routinely
make a mockery of the protection that
comes from living on one side of a
border versus the other right a huge
amount of radioactive material landed in
the Pacific Northwest from Fukushima yep
right the the stuff is not contained
gain of function research took over the
world right so AI is not going to stop
at Borders so given all of that we need
a structure and the correct
focus is subsidiarity something that
does not manage things above the level
that they need to be managed but manages
everything at the appropriate level and
that means there's going to be a good
bit of structure
up at the do I remember that that's a
concept originally from the Catholic
Church yes it is
amazing yeah it is amazing I heard uh
Jordan Peterson mentioned it recently so
it's interesting I've never heard of it
until
I've forgotten who it was who pointed me
to it but
um
oh I said Anonymous account with the
pseudonym that was also Ben Franklin
pseudonym but it doesn't matter
um
yes you need something that is capable
of managing these things above the
national level the financial
collapse
radioactive materials toxins oceans
atmospheres all of these things have to
be managed and they can't be capturable
and do I think I know how to do that
at one level yes you need to gather
all of the people who have relevant
expertise and no conflict of interest
and you need to have conversations in
which you game this stuff out and then
you need to figure out how to test what
the unintended consequences of various
structures are but do I think I know
what the answers that process would come
up with are no I think I'd be crazy to
imagine that I did
okay uh
two more the final one is just a comment
thoughts on chat gbt4 seeming to be
orders of magnitude better at
understanding emotional context and
spatial awareness than its predecessors
um that sounds like something I would
like to have thoughts about
um I don't I I haven't I haven't gone
there I haven't touched it I haven't
looked at it directly at all so you have
and you have experience with it I don't
know I think you will find this
predicted in the piece I wrote in 2016
which I will release I am working
towards putting it into the world
um but let's just put it this way you
know what else does this
children
what does what pick up the ability to
read emotions
in a world emotional context and spatial
awareness yeah and so basic point is
what they've done is they've created a
developmental environment that
developmental environment has produced
cognition that surprises those who built
the thing that picked it up but the
basic point is look we've seen this and
you need to be looking at the biological
analog and admitting how much you don't
know about how that works
you don't want your AI to fledge
well there it is
mail final uh male power lifter IDs as
woman breaks woman's record held by
trans athlete
uh somebody beat zubi is that what I get
no that would be zubi oh doing it I mean
this is zoobie basically did this
without actually competing right but
this is this is the way to point
this is one way to point out this
ludicracy
ludacrosity Ludacris stupidity of
um the environment with regard to
trans women athletes I think bloodrocity
is your hip-hop name ludacrosity yeah
okay
no
I just I feel like given that one of my
actual relatives was named hilarious
highing yes but maybe it should be
something a play on that I think this is
a play hilarious without the O Zach just
give me a look like no it's actually one
of one of your relatives was named
hilarious hilarious High yeah um yeah
anyway
um yeah
we would have had to name you hilarious
um
yeah
you know self ID
allowing you to cheat while the
activists cry about you're killing us
with your rules and fairness yeah logic
logic and like being grounded in reality
uh is
you know I said this to you this week
recently it's like
as horrifying as the chaos and the lies
and the delusions and there's so many of
them over covid have been
for most of them I can I can put myself
in a position and twist myself around
enough to be like okay maybe I can maybe
I can see how
BB
the trans stuff at this point
like sex isn't real all you have to do
is call yourself a woman and you're a
woman I'm gonna put on a lipstick and
heels and I'm a woman
I really I really cannot understand
how anyone is buying this
I just I I
am utterly baffled
I think the people who are doing it are
also baffled that it's worth but it's
working yeah
oh my God
I yeah I don't
you could put as many
ludacrosity Laden scenarios together as
you want and somehow some substantial
portion of the population will still not
see it they will you're the bigot
yep you're transphobic Nazi is what you
are
yeah
the number of people who will buy that
is uh by that is shocking
so I mean if that
like are
people who think
printing on lipstick makes you a woman
and therefore you should be against
women
I think we can convince some of other
things
what I think you know how we're looking
for a new term are we yes because nobody
can figure out how to define woman
lipstick wearer
I mean come on adult human female was
good but lipstick wear now that's
specific
[Laughter]
Shopper oh oh
um hysterical
you might just go oh man pair of shoe
hammer
[Laughter]
I
yep it's so
sexist
oh you are a reality phobe
I I cannot
thank you I was hoping you would cower
was doing something that someone had an
actual event who said an official record
what the thing you're talking are you
miked no
I'm just telling you guys but I don't
know what well you were the question
that referred to wondering if this was
something like what zooby did just sort
of in a video oh but some this actually
happened well I'm hearing in the chat
that apparently this is something the
official record has been at least from
what the questions that it sounds like
rebroken by a trans woman
um
but it's just I I don't have a lot of
info from the chat but apparently it's
real
I agree that means I've said it before
like
given everything else we are wrestling
with women's sports don't matter
but uh
all these people claiming to care about
civil rights and
and fairness and and allowing people to
live their best lives
uh and then
what the last
when did when was Title IX 70 sometime
I think yeah so you know title line of
course has become an Abomination it's
become uh captured and it does a lot of
things it was never supposed to do now
but
um
at the very least it's obviously the
death of women's sports
yeah
and somehow you've got a whole bunch of
people and some of them are the same
people who are celebrating when their
little child declares themselves trans
you've got a bunch of people
Hooten and hollering on the sidelines
you go girl
a girl
it's not a girl I'll never be a girl
stop it
yeah
my feeling is you know you you say and I
I'm Jarred to hear you say it
um that women's sports don't matter in
comparison to some of the other issues
but but it's the most obvious place
well I agree and I I guess here's you
know you've got sophistry which keeps
you
trying to explain the obvious right we
need the opposite of that and my feeling
is
anytime somebody wants to do this with
respect to sports who are you to exclude
this person from their right to compete
the answer is uh do that with prisons
right do that with male sex offenders
who inside are really women
yeah and oh oh you you think criminals
deserve it they get do you you know
you're not allowed to think that but
okay do it with domestic abuse shelters
oh is she asking for it is she asking
for it in the future really
because that's what you're saying yeah
that's the argument yeah that's the
argument you're making stop it
we were so much we were in so many
better places until this and now we are
inviting predators and would-be
criminals into our Spaces by decorating
them in flowers and claiming they are
neither Predators nor criminals not okay
nope and so yeah we're in sports by
comparison doesn't matter it's important
but important comparison like I you know
I've played Sports I I think it's I it's
it was a wonderful innovation
to um
require some funding for women's sports
such that
female athletes actually had a chance to
compete in a way that really there
wasn't much opportunity before because
people aren't as most people aren't as
interested as Spectators right and it
doesn't you know it doesn't have the
same history and there's a lot of you
know solid evolutionary reasons for that
but that doesn't mean that women
shouldn't be allowed to compete and this
is
the death of uh competition between
women but it's much much much worse than
that yeah much much worse than that
absolutely all right well well that got
dark on that happy note AI
and the obliteration of women's rights
yeah
what else are we talking about no covet
nonsense yeah all that toxic mold
any questions but not for three weeks
because we will not be doing a q a for
three weeks we will be back next week
with episode 169 but we'll then uh not
be doing a q a and we'll be gone the
week after that uh but we will be back
next year next year
also next year but yeah
we were going to go light
failed at that apparently yes flowers
springtime
not for Hitler
that was on you I was not gonna raise
Hitler at all I was gonna just run out
the clock I was hoping that you would
break into songs
and Germany oh well there are you broken
this it is okay
until we see you next time guys be good
to the ones you love eat good food
I'm gonna I'm gonna redo that are you
doing that yeah because because I took
him by surprise our producer yes Dan
Hitler
not as much no no it's good and dead no
yeah
we're allowed to say that about him that
he's dead good and dead
the only good Hitler is a dead Hitler
that was light
mmm it's been a weird week it has been
there
until we see you next time because of
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside
be well everyone
[Music]
foreign